so you're telling me that we finished
the album we're about to go on tour yeah
and until we go on tour we have to stay
at this nice place and we have to cook
for everyone yeah that makes zero sense
that's not even funny like it's not even
a funny concept like that's just
horrible why like cuz we're gonna [ __ ]
it up so bad
never doubt yourself bro well I've been
waiting for this moment with a feed
y'all some real nasty [ __ ] you got some
snake you got some bull testicles
oh so being a bull watching over from
heaven to seeing your balls getting get
it in and about three [ __ ] dumbasses
can you teach you how to make sushi
clothes it's a lot about technique order
in to San Jose yes yeah me what the
knife is kind of like feel like it's
already at the extension of my hand I
want to be your girlfriend's ammonia
break first yeah yeah
[Music]
one two three testes oh [ __ ] I'm sorry
too whoever's gonna eat this this is the
most [ __ ] up cooking show after it is
being gog have been preparing the food
for this party for such a long time I
got one last question for you and are
you proud of us
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion welcome to the feast mansion
that was a good one I try I'm here I'm
I'm here every Wednesday